[Musica]
ok ha insegnato e insegna
ho iniziato a insegnare disegno per
raccontare alle persone
tutto quello che il disegno ha insegnato
a me nell'arco della vita sulla vita
sono qui per dirvi che saper disegnare è
qualcosa che va ben oltre il fare un bel
disegno
il disegno è una porta verso la
conoscenza di se stessi e del mondo ed è
anche un linguaggio infinito illimitato
alla portata di tutti il tema di oggi è
tornare a crederci
io vorrei invitarvi a tornare a credere
alla possibilità di meravigliarvi di voi
stessi magari perché no
attraverso il disegno perché questo
perché le parole degli altri
a volte ci frenano quante volte magari
abbiamo sentito dire quando eravamo
piccoli o perché no anche da adulti che
disegnare è una cosa stupida o è
un'attività inutile che non può essere
un lavoro e quante volte ci siamo
sentiti dire la frase non sei capace non
necessariamente nell'ambito del disegno
come ho detto prima le parole degli
altri
frenano le paure degli altri frenano e
ci portano spesso a prendere binari che
sono molto lontani dai nostri veri
desideri
il disegno nella pratica continua
scusate nella pratica continua ci mostra
come è possibile superare noi stessi
superare le nostre stesse aspettative
per raggiungere dei risultati che sono
sconvolgenti ci fanno meravigliare e
quindi il disegno rimane una grandissima
metafora di quella che può essere la
nostra esperienza di vita
questi sono disegni di alcuni miei
allievi
i miei allievi vanno dai 13 anni ai 70
anni ed è bellissimo vedere come una
persona intraprende un percorso e si
meraviglia del suo cambiamento
parlando di disegno però dobbiamo
parlare delle sue componenti
fondamentali il segno il segno ha dato
dal movimento e dallo strumento il segno
racconta il nostro carattere
racconta il modo in cui noi agiamo non
solo sulla carta ma anche nella vita
e poi c'è la visione ovvero il modo in
cui noi vediamo la realtà che si traduce
sulla carta nel modo in cui noi la
rappresentiamo sei mia visione insieme
nella pratica vanno a stimolare il
sistema nervoso
cosa significa che stesse ma nervoso
diventa più ricettivo si apre si espande
quindi diventiamo più sensibili più
capaci di percepire le sottigliezze i
dettagli questa cosa incide tantissimo
sul risultato chiaramente ma incide
anche sulla nostra consapevolezza quindi
sulla nostra autostima e così via
ciclicamente perché il disdegno migliora
nel tempo e continua a migliorare e
continua a farci meravigliare kimon
nicolaides le cui parole sono state
riportate nel libro disegnare in modo
naturale sosteneva che c'è una grande
differenza tra il saper disegnare e il
fare disegni il disegno in quanto
oggetto è una dimostrazione è un
risultato attesta un successo ed è ciò
che tutti si aspettano ma ciò che conta
veramente è quel percorso meraviglioso
che ci conduce ad affinare la nostra
consapevolezza nei confronti della vita
quindi cambia il nostro modo di
osservare e di vivere la vita nel
disegnare parlando di cose concrete
il disegno quindi migliora il nostro
modo di vedere la realtà così com'è
migliora la nostra capacità di
utilizzare il corpo e il movimento in
modo funzionale ci dà la capacità di
sintesi
ovvero di trovare nella realtà
essenziale però fa bene anche alla
progettazione
cosa significa noi possiamo partire da
una realtà preesistente elaborarla per
generare una nuova realtà fa bene a
pazienza memoria e attenzione ci insegna
la dedizione e ci insegna anche la
determinazione
ecco perché mi piace insegnare disegno
soprattutto agli adulti perché è
bellissimo vedere quando un adulto
decide di intraprendere un viaggio che
non è un viaggio soltanto esterno è un
viaggio dentro di sé e decide di
scoprire le nuove aspetti di sé il
disegno fa emergere talenti che non sono
necessariamente legati all'arte visiva
fa sorprendere perché apre delle porte
che fino ad allora erano rimaste chiuse
quindi medici avvocati ingegneri anche
gli architetti che al giorno d'oggi
disegnano pochissimi possono imparare a
disegnare per imparare a progettare
spazi e processi per imparare a trovare
soluzioni attraverso un pensiero che è
un pensiero visivo possono imparare a
usare la loro mente in un modo molto
diverso rispetto a come la mente
lavorano il quotidiano ma il disegno è
anche terapia nel senso che può aiutare
persone che hanno difficoltà ad esempio
motorie oppure persone che hanno
difficoltà di dislessia disgrafia
ma anche accompagnare persone che stanno
seguendo una cura o un percorso di
riabilitazione una terapia perché il
disegno può essere anche raccontato così
è uno spazio senza spazio e senza tempo
tra due parentesi nel percorso della
vita
in quell'istante l'istante della pratica
del disegno la persona mette da parte il
suo io e si fonde con l'esistenza in
quel momento c'è solo esistenza e
creazione quindi la persona si apre
molto più facilmente al cambiamento
quindi le arti per me sono un luogo
speciale e vorrei che fossero un luogo
speciale per tutti il luogo per
conoscersi senza necessariamente farne
una professione per me sono uno spazio
carico di dignità che tutti dovrebbero
imparare a comprendere e accettare
in questo senso dagli adulti ai bambini
ma dico soprattutto gli adulti perché
sono gli adulti che poi accompagnano i
bambini nel loro percorso prendono delle
decisioni per loro per cui il mio invito
è quello di tornare a casa con una
visione diversa di ciò che è il disegno
di ciò che sono le arti e se nicolaides
sosteneva che intangibile è più
interessante del tangibile e che anche
il percorso conta quanto la meta quanto
il risultato allora il disegno può
essere anche qualcos'altro può staccarsi
da ciò che è rappresentazione per farsi
puro segno per diventare performance
qualcosa che racconti un'azione
un'esperienza quindi una sorta di mappa
che racconta un istante di esperire
lui è paolo gozzetti e siamo ora andremo
a raccontarvi qualcosa
grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]